actually i want to go back to how japan
is super varied because i actually
never understood that about japan being
such a tiny island country and yet
having
even dialect be so different throughout
all of japan
how is that possible like how did that
even happen like how did we stay so
separated in all of our like
clans so to speak look at the uk right
yeah like
the uk is similar yeah i guess so it's
like 20 different accents just in london
yeah if you drive 10 minutes it's a
totally different accent sometimes
yeah and i feel like it's certainly like
if a country's been around for a while
it happens right especially because
there was before travel was widely
you know available i guess i mean in the
case with japan like
brief history of japan like japan was
20 pieces yeah it was in like you know
50 different pieces and each of them was
technically their own country
until it was all founded in like the
1600s so
for like over 2 3 000 years each place
was just like a different country yeah
it just blows my mind because like even
so i'm in shizuoka right and i'm like on
the side that's
rather close to tokyo um it takes longer
to get to the opposite side of shizuoka
than it does to go to tokyo and i went
there for like some kind of job
and i couldn't understand the shopkeep
person
i didn't figure it out i was like i'm so
sorry and i have
a shizuoka accent in japanese like i
accidentally let like the dialect slip
and stuff
but even then i was like i don't i i
can't figure you out like i
do you speak english yeah it's crazy
it's great like i had that same thing
like when i because my family's from
miyagi which is up north right
and like i have so many of like my
grandma and granddad's like
cousins who still live in like [ __ ]
tiny villages in the middle of like the
mountains
where it's like there are some villages
that have their own like village
specific dialect
wow and like village specific like words
and i remember like
one of them like came out to the city to
like see my grandma for like
you know in like first time like 15
years or something wow
she just came out and she did like a lot
of like japanese dialects
have like they end their sentences in a
very like specific way
yeah the ending is specific the ending
is very specific right right so like in
you know uh what's like an example like
in in sendai normally right we end all
of our sentences in bit
uh
turns into just whatever different [ __ ]
when it comes to dialects yeah so ours
has been
yeah i've been i've been winging it man
when people i just say oh i sold this
and then i'm like am i doing it right i
don't [ __ ] know i just hit people
yeah that's fine because that's like the
standard right yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a
standard goal like there's standard
regular language
like cousin dead ass she ended all of
her sentences with
yeah and i'm just like
and i was just like the weave inside of
me is frothing right
and it's so
why would this like 90 something year
old like four foot tall grandma
be putting on her ending all of
super tiny village in the middle of
nowhere in miyagi and you will find a
village where everyone
ends their sentences so these people who
are posting online were secretly from
japan the whole time the whole time
oh my god my eyes are truly open
oh that's you know older people in i
don't know if it's all in japan but like
in my
area not eat becomes
yeah for us so like yeah like um
right but like not like that though
right it literally is like dacha type of
ending yeah it's like so soda
like it's like dead ass like i wish i
was making that up
yeah but it's so [ __ ] weird i'm like
that is [ __ ] adorable but you're also
like
93. you're like 100 years old
and you're saying yeah yeah which one
which one says at the end
of the other village it's an okinawa
right yeah they all walk around like
this
that's how they say hello no no
oh my god i'm curious like do you ever
hear a british accent or like an english
dialect that you have trouble
understanding
there will be one i guarantee other
you'll be like what the [ __ ] are they
saying i mean honestly i haven't
i'm sure there are i just haven't come
across anything cockney for me
is like that's pretty tame yeah really
the more north you go the more like what
the [ __ ] did you just say yeah
like like especially in england the more
north i go the more like you start you
start you start squinting with your ears
just be like
because they what they do is they start
replacing common words
with just their own version and
sometimes it's that person specific
but everyone around them just knows
because it's like everyone i don't know
it's really bizarre
yeah yeah but everyone just says the
same thing and it was just really
bizarre can you mimic
one i couldn't even man like there's so
many british words that when people tell
me that i'm like i don't know that means
on its own but when used in a sentence
i'm like i know what he's talking about
i feel like in the uk the further north
you go the more
the sentence just turns into like bush
yeah something like that
like there was there was a post on
twitter it was like what is this and it
was like british people were applying it
was an alleyway but there was like there
was like
10 different ways of saying an alleyway
in like british england well it's not
official
but like slang yeah and then it was like
i saw it because it was a quote
she was like americans must be losing
their mind right now
there was there was tons i got to find
this tweet it was like crazy just i call
an alleyway but again then again i've
been americanized
yeah doing this job i've had to really
like kick out the
very dialect specific words i say cell
phone i say elevate yeah like
oh really yeah yeah yeah yeah because i
used to say lift
but yeah every time i start apartments
what the hell is a lift oh instead of
loft
uh flat
what are you on about [ __ ] you saying
rainer
oh yeah yeah yeah but they're so
contextual though like you can
figure it out like sometimes sometimes
but
if you understand what they're saying in
the first part but there's been so many
moments where i
thought this was just like a universal
word until
i said it to an american they were like
what's that
because like i always thought like
laurie oh yeah
it was just like everyone said it a
lorry driver yeah driver
how do you spell it l-o-o
so it's not a truck it's a lorry well
you know like a
pram right instead of a stroller yeah
yeah
like in america it's a stroller right
you put your baby in a stroller no in in
australia we call it a prank
i prefer baby car yeah i was gonna say i
i prefer
baby carriage
yeah but it's like i thought everyone in
the world called it a pram
and you know babies wear nappies right
no no yeah we're nappies yeah well yeah
okay i was like what is it
yeah like what are they wearing
you know